Okay.
So that's another issue that I'd like to bring up because one of the things,
I cannot say grout is the alliance between the postmodernists and the Neo
Marxists.
I can't understand the causal relationship there because the,
tell me if you disagree with this.
Okay.
Because,
um,
I'm a psychologist,
not a sociologist and so I'm dabbling in things that are outside of my field of
expertise and there is some danger in that.
But the scent,
the central postmodernist claim seems to me that because there's a near infinite
number of ways to interpret a complex set of phenomena,
which,
which actually happens to be the case,
that you can't make a case that any of those modes of interpretation,
our canonical,
and so if they're not canonical,
if that,
if that canonical element isn't based in some kind of reality,
then it serves some other master.
And so the master that it hypothetically serves for the postmodernists is
nothing but power because that seems to be everything that they believe in.
They don't believe in competence.
They don't believe in authority.
They don't seem to believe in an objective world because everything is language
mediated.
So it's an extraordinarily cynical perspective that that because there's an
infinite number of interpretations,
none of them are canonical,
you can attribute it to everything to power and dominance.
Okay.
So that,
that seemed like a reasonable summary of the
radical relativism.
Okay.
It's a radical relativism now.
But the strange thing is despite,
okay,
and so what goes along with that is the demolition of grand narratives.
And so that would be associated,
for example,
with the rejection of thinkers like young and Eric Norman because of course
their foundational thinkers,
um,
in relationship to the idea that there are embodied grand narratives that's
never touched.
But then despite the fact that the grand narrative is rejected,
there's a neo Marxism that's tightly,
tightly allied with postmodernism.
It also seems to shade into this strange identity politics.
And I don't,
two things,
I don't understand the causal relationship there.
Like the,
the skeptical part of me thinks that postmodernism was a,
was an intellectual,
it's intellectual camouflage for the continuation of the kind of pathological
Marxism that produced the Soviet Union.
And that has no independent existence as an intellectual field whatsoever.
But I still can't understand how the postmodernists can make the no grand
narrative claim,
but then immerse themselves in this grand narrative.
W W without anyone pointing out the evidence contradictions.
Like I don't understand that.
So what do you think about that?
Well,
I can only speak about literary and professors really,
and they seem to me almost universally in the u s to being very naive or they,
they,
they seem to know nothing about actual history,
political science or economics.
It's simply an attitude.
They have an attitude and it would,
in Marxism becomes simply a badge by which they telegraph their,
um,
their solidarity with a working class that they have nothing to do with.
Right.
I mean,
really nothing but contempt.
Yes.
And the thing is that the,
the campus leftists are almost notorious for their,
uh,
for their rather snobbish treatment of staff.
I mean they don't,
they don't have any rapport with the actual working class members of the,
um,
of the infrastructure,
the janitor,
the janitors,
and even the,
even the secretaries,
there's a kind of high and mighty aristocracy,
you know,
about these have just,
these are people who,
um,
who have wandered into the English department.
Right.
And we're products of a time when,
um,
during the,
the new criticism they wait with when history with history and psychology had
been excluded.
I mean,
my ambition,
okay.
Was I love the new criticism okay.
As,
as a style of textual analysis.
Right.
And,
and the,
and the new criticism had multiple interpretations.
Okay.
That were possible.
And,
and they were encouraged.
In fact,
one of the,
you know,
one of the great projects was made in Max series,
20th century views.
What you had at least some books.
I adored them in college and it was about Jane Austin or about Emily Bronte or
about Wordsworth.
And they were collections of alternate views of the same thing.
The idea that no more,
no alternative views.
And there was no relativistic situational kind of,
kind of an interpretive approach is nonsense.
Okay.
About,
but the point was we needed to restore right history to literary literary study.
Okay.
And we needed to add psychology to it because it was,
there was great animus against Freud.
And when I arrived in,
in graduate school,
in fact,
I actually went into the director of graduate studies and protested the way
Freud and Freud and were used as as negative terms pay in a sneering way by that
very wasp professors.
Right.
So we need to do it.
Actually,
it seemed like we were moving there.
It can be in the early 1970s was a great period of psycho biography about great.
About political figures.
Okay.
So I thought it's happening in all of a sudden it all got short circuited by
this arrival,
you know,
of of poststructuralism and postmodernism and the in the,
in the 1970s.
All right.
Um,
so I,
I feel,
I am an old historicist okay.
Not,
not a new historicist.
So I mean,
I think new stores,
so it was an absolute scam.
Right?
And it's like,
it just a way,
it's like tweezers.
You'd like just,
you know,
you pick a little bit of this,
a little bit of that,
a little bit of that.
You make a little tiny salad.
I'm going to say I'm selling this atomize thing.
Okay.
It's supposed to mean something.
It's all can be very superficial,
very cynical,
very distance.
I like,
I am a,
I am a product.
Okay.
Of Old historicism German philology.
I decided my,
my first choice of a profession when I was a child would was Egyptology
archaeology.
Everything I ever think about or say is,
is related to an enormous time scheme.
Okay.
From,
from antiquity and indeed from the Stone Age.
Right.
And that is the problem with,
with these people,
they're their mouth educated,
the postmodernist and academic Marxists.
Okay.
Our mount educated embarrassingly so.
They know nothing before the present full call.
Okay.
It's absolutely a joke before the enlightenment.
Hey Dave,
perhaps he might be useful to people to talk about what happened after
neoclassicism,
which by the way,
he failed to notice a lot of what he was talking about.
Okay.
Turns out to see be simply the hangover of neoclassicism.
Okay,
this,
this is how ignorant that man was.
I mean,
his head was,
he was not talented as a researcher.
He knew absolutely nothing.
Okay with,
you know,
nothing about antiquity.
How can you make any kind of large structure?
While I'm large mechanism,
you know,
to analyze western culture without knowing about classical antiquity.